good hey there folks Chris waters here
in San Francisco California with a man
who's been spending a lot of time in san
francisco california the watchdog's to
version joining me is Johnathan Mohan
the creative director of watch dogs too
in order to make it an authentic place
there's a lot of different beats you
need to hit there's a lot of stuff to
goes into building a city on talk to you
about that and let's start with sort of
the big thing the landmarks I mean you
got to have your babe regina bridge your
sutro tower how do you go about like
getting those things just right I think
one of the challenges first of all the
barriers gigantic so it's really big
you're not like put it all into the game
so you have to pick the best spots so I
think what the team did really well is
the identified dealt with landmarks like
sooo true towers and everything and then
they started to craft the city making
sure that we align those things properly
because if you start cutting entire
district or shrinking down to two
streets like something that's gigantic
you don't want to make the feeling wrong
so I think they did an amazing job at
looking at going into a certain area
looking at the vistas from the Marine
County where's the bridge is a line with
where we are right now and then going on
another area and then making sure that's
from that area they understand the
alignment with a few compromises that
people could could understand if they
really live in the city I think it did a
spectacular job to make sure that the
point of references are there and then
it gets to the street level
well the Golden Gate Bridge was one of
the challenging one for us like the real
bridge is gigantic so when you get from
marine Conte and you look at it and like
for us it was a okay we're gonna have to
scale up a lot like I got a huge fan of
making big well just for the sake of
making them big but when we walked in
here and look at the barrier and the
bridge and how the vistas with Alcatraz
and everything was going on said okay
from if we don't like at least double
the size of our game it's going to be
laughable when are we going to build
that like like we need to add those this
that's right
you
a neighborhoods feel isn't just the
great view you have of Coit Tower it's
what kind of buildings are there what
kind of you know street size and traffic
flow where the key things to sort of
extracting that the spirit of a
neighborhood while still kind of you
know solving the space problem I take
one of the paint the main thing is you
need to come here like you cannot just
google map the place or like look at the
ad the thing from from the internet like
you need to understand how it feels to
walk on the streets because anybody can
nail the landmarks probably the
alignment is very complicated but once
you've done that then how can you with
those modifications still keep the soul
of every area and that was very
important to us
I want to talk to you about Chicago you
built a city there what are the kind of
big lessons from watchdogs that you
applied when you were building San
Francisco and watchdogs to spending more
time with the people in the streets we
did interviews with people that lives in
San Francisco we talked a lot to people
who were with us when we Scout the areas
to learn more about the vibes and the
personal garage that there's on certain
people even going to the hipsters and
the techies and all of these things and
the impact of gentrification and all of
that stuff and airing what people have
to say about it and the different angles
so we could better understand the vibes
of it so when you talk about the people
i mean does that inform like the stuff
you see on their phones when you kind of
take a peek or the conversations you
overhear how do those people in san
francisco and watchdogs to differ from
the Chicagoans of watchdogs all there is
that there's definitely into the kind of
information you get into their profiler
is definitely one thing but it's the
stuff they talk about and in the second
game we wanted to go a good for deep
into the city so we have what we go like
smaller operations we have the
operations of that sack that are like
the main stuff that talks about the big
subject that are also relating to San
Francisco a lot but then talking about
gentrification more specifically for
example then you can get into smaller
stories you can discover from the people
who talk on the street and that unlock
stuff you can dig into and expose to the
people afterwards so those are ways for
us to inspire ourselves to what people
are thinking on at the street level of a
of the different companies of the impact
of Silicon Valley's on their lives and
that kind of stuff and that sped us a
lot into
imagination please deep blue
so i have to tell you john from one of
my favorite moments from that III
trailer was seeing a quick glimpse of
the bush man who for folks who don't
know is a panhandler who sits hiding
behind the bush waiting to scare
passers-by how did you guys go about
sort of populating your world these very
specific things that you know you're not
reading about that guy on national news
well it's a it's just by coming here
just you just cross around like these
things that YouTube is also pretty good
at showing people who went to San
Francisco with the internet these days
you can also just follow people who
share what they thought was cool about
San Francisco and in the end for a game
like we're interested in what is cool so
like the people and who are then there's
quite a few easter eggs of of landmarks
like and also including certain versions
and there so we can actually create this
parts that you would have in san
francisco so that people who either live
there or been here you could have a
chance to say hey wait a minute like I I
live that experience that's amazing
those dish of who Norman for us or are
important this building behind us
Ubisoft SF place where we make South
Park rocksmith and where you make hot
videos like this one having this kid
this billion game is pretty cool for me
how did you guys decide to put Ubisoft
in SF in there I mean your doctor after
that was a no-brainer like I mean if you
if you start doing cities and start
making interesting references or
indirect references to companies might
as well start having a reference of your
own company and I have fun with your own
stuff so we have interesting stuff going
on surrounding Ubisoft and watch legs
interesting stuff you'd play coy about
that for now I'm not gonna talk about
that alright easter egg important is to
remain Easter eggs or else it's not
being discovered very true so folks want
to find the Ubisoft building in watch
dogs to one of the other hands on
November 15 on pc ps4 and Xbox Jonathan
thanks so much for talking about San
Francisco really looking forward to
exploring the place see my own workplace
and discovering what the virtual San
Francisco has to offer
you